the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
well it's promises we're gonna cover no
new material today we've just hit the
end of part 2 of the course which I
think you'll agree with me was probably
the most technically challenging part
who would disagree I wonder I didn't
think so so I wanted a bit of review and
help you guys out with problem set seven
since I've got a couple of fun problems
I think they're fun because they're
actually fairly realistic like the last
one will it blend the ap1000 edition
well you'll actually analyze if we've
given the actual specification sheet of
an ap1000 reactor which is a modern
reactor that's being built now can you
determine its k effective using the to
group the two energy group approximation
and just to show you guys that this
isn't crazy I've got the ap1000 spec
sheet up here so who got a chance to
take a look at pset seven good that's a
lot of hands alright I I highly
recommend everyone look at it ahead of
time because it is the doozy and it will
be the last doozy of this course so part
three of the course is lighter because
most your other courses are gonna go
nuts after Thanksgiving as far as I know
right yeah this one's not so doing my
best to equalize your total course load
this semester by making this course
crazy now and lighten up when final
season comes so I've got the spec sheet
for the ap1000 right here that actually
goes over a description of what the core
is like the materials that are used how
many fuel rods there are how many
assemblies there are basically what the
core is made of and what I want to do is
jump to the end where they actually talk
about the analytical techniques used in
the core design what I want to show you
is for nuclear design of the core to get
axial power distributions look at that
to group diffusion Theory the same stuff
that we just learned right here for
axial power distribution control rod
Worth's one-dimensional to group
diffusion theory these are problems that
you can solve with the stuff that we've
done over the past week and a half they
have a little more complexity and that
they keep all the spatial variance in
there
so probably done with computers however
when they make the same equations that
you do so Westinghouse is making the
same assumptions that we made in this
course they have a lot more complexity
in that there you know we just had cross
sections or macroscopic cross sections
as a function of energy but you may also
think about it as a function of position
and a function of temperature since as
we started alluding to on what was today
it's on Wednesday know Tuesday what day
is it now
it's Thursday thank you so definitely on
Tuesday we started talking about how
cross sections change with temperature
and so really if we want to go crazy on
that neutron transport equation these
cross sections will be functions of
energy temperature and position and so
that's how this reactor would have
actually been designed but you're going
to do a simpler approximation and take
all of the information about the core
and an ap1000 blend it so homogenized it
figure out what the average atomic
fractions of all the different things in
it are and calculate is K effective so I
think is a pretty cool problem to do I
haven't seen it done in the courses here
but I want to see how you how it turns
out and you might find it's surprisingly
different from one because we make a lot
a lot of simplifications that actually
matter quite a bit but to help you parse
this spec sheet well actually why don't
I show you the problem first we'll go
through a few of the different things
that I've simplified the problem to make
it not so tedious but I also want to
make sure you understand what to do so
the simple the simple statement is
calculate K effective of the ap1000
using two group diffusion theory which
means you've got a criticality condition
from the two group approximation and I'd
like to go over what that is right now
let's so let's write out if we had a two
group so there are two Energy Group
equations for gains and losses of
neutrons in the fast and thermal group
what would it look like what are the
gain terms
yep there's gonna be some average new
times Sigma fission fast times flux fast
plus Sigma fission thermal times flux
Thermal any other sources of neutrons
into the fast group I don't think so
what about sinks
how do neutrons leave the fast group yep
by absorption how else yep
scattering from the fast to the thermal
group how else
leakage so there'll be some diffusion
constant fast times some fast geometric
buckling squared and yeah I think that's
it no that needs a Phi as well fast okay
cool
what about the thermal group what are
the sources of thermal neutrons yep
scattering from the fast group so this
same term right here fast a thermal
times Phi fast and what are the losses
leakage and absorption they look pretty
familiar thermal by thermal plus the
thermal BG squared by thermal and that's
C T okay the hard part in this problem
is going to be doing these averages this
is the part that we haven't explicitly
done on the board and I want to show you
yeah this one top equation that should
be a I'll make the apps really curly
curve and those are straight T's these
are curly FS
okay great thank you so the hard part is
going to be doing cross section averages
we've just kind of written them as hey
they're average cross sections in an
average cross section would look
something like the integral from a
minimum to a maximum of the cross
section as a function of energy times
the flux over the same integral without
the cross section
this is where I want to point out
something that I want you to remember
for the rest of this course and the rest
of your life you don't have to do things
analytically if you don't want to unless
it's explicitly stated that you have to
so part of this pset is to drill in the
idea that it's the future we have
computers and you can do numerical
integration with data remember on one of
the second problem sets I showed you
guys the web plot digitizer how you can
extract information from a printed graph
well a lot of times what you already
have is that data and you'll have to
then integrate that numerically in
something as simple as Excel or as
complicated as MATLAB or something worse
whatever tool you choose to use I'll be
using excel because it's kind of the
lowest common denominator and so to show
you guys you don't need to know any
fancy software to actually solve these
problems so let's go through getting
some of this data right now let's say
that the cutoff between fast and thermal
so if we were doing a fast cross section
the cutoff would be at one Evie and our
max would be let's say 10 MeV which
would be the top of the fission birth
spectrum or the Chi spectrum one UV that
would be 10 MeV so all that's left is
you need tabulated values for the cross
sections and the fluxes and then you can
perform this numerical integral I've
given you tabulated values for the
fluxes wherever that is yep use the
attached ap1000 tabulated Neutron flux
profile which opens that's awesome so
I've given you the approximate Neutron
flux in neutrons per centimeter squared
per second as a function of neutron
energy and so you can tell for a low
Neutron energy there aren't any ultra
cold neutrons in this problem though
there are in the problem right before
because remember the we'll see now is
when we'll see but if we scale down we
get down to the thermal regions where
it's in the EVM levels you start to see
pretty significant Neutron fluxes on the
rail
of 10 to the 14th neutrons for
centimeter squared per second so that
value of 10 to the 14th for flux that
we've been using in all our previous
problem sets it's because that's what we
actually get this flux spectrum and the
picture of it that we have here was
taken from the MIT reactor because it's
representative of a pressurized water
reactor
the only difference here is this is the
spectrum from the fast flux trap you
don't usually see that fast to thermal
ratio in a thermal reactor but it's the
closest spectrum that I was even easily
able to get my hands on and it's not
that unrepresentative and the reaction
rates for things aren't gonna be that
different because most of the reaction
rates the cross-sections down here are
in the like thousands of barns level and
the cross-sections here are in the one
barn level it's pretty much any fast
cross-section for anything about a barn
that's a good rule of thumb so it's not
going to change total reaction rates
that much and that's why I'm not worried
about making a taking the fast flux
spectrum from the MIT reactor and
pretending like it's the ap1000 it's not
horribly that far off and it's at the
right order of magnitude which is
important so that data I give you let's
talk about how to get this data the
macroscopic cross-sections
so if you remember a macroscopic
cross-section is a microscopic
cross-section times a number density and
that's for one single isotope if you
have a mix of isotopes then your total
averaged cross-section for all different
types of atoms is going to be a sum and
make it very different over all of your
isotopic possible ores all your possible
isotopes of the atom fraction of that
isotope times the number density of that
isotope times the microscopic
cross-section of that reaction for that
isotope I'm sorry the atom fraction is
included in the number density let's
just simplify this a little bit
the total number density of that isotope
that'll be in atoms per cubic centimeter
times the cross-section for that
particular isotope which is in
centimeters squared which leads you to a
one over centimeter macroscopic cross
section and so let's say we were summing
up something like stainless steel which
happened to be iron 18 chrome 10 nickel
not only would you have to then get the
number densities of iron chrome and
nickel but you have to look at which
isotopes there are so if we want it to
get the macroscopic cross section for
stainless steel we'd have to split this
into the stable isotopes of iron the
stable isotopes of chrome and the stable
isotopes of nickel and then say it's
this number density times of
cross-section Plus this number density
times a cross-section and so on and so
on and so on the easy way to do get
those number densities if you take the
number density of your stainless steel
times the atom fraction of that isotope
that should give you the number density
of that isotope this makes sense to
everybody
does anyone not know how to get a number
density of a material from its basic
chemical properties okay
so a number density is in atoms per
cubic centimeter and usually we would
have something like its density which
would be grams per cubic centimeter so
if we take density in grams per
centimeter cubed and x Avogadro's number
and divide by I'll just put a / symbol
here the molar mass of a god rose number
is given in atoms per mole and divided
by molar mass units are given in what is
it grams per mole so that's going to be
like moles per gram the grams cancel the
moles cancel and you get atoms per cubic
centimeter so to get a number density
you can take the density of the material
you know for stainless steel it's like
eight grams per cubic centimeter times
Avogadro's number say 6 times 10 to the
23rd this would be like 8 grams per
centimeter cubed or so time or divided
by the molar mass or the average molar
mass of stainless steel I'm guessing
that's around 56 grams per mole and then
you'll get a number density and typical
solid number densities tend to range
from like 10 to the 26 to 10 to the 28
it'll be atoms per meter cube so it's
gonna be around like 21 to 23 atoms per
centimeter cubed so if you end up with
something way outside those bounds
you've probably got some sort of unit or
power error so that'll help you check
your math to make sure you get the
number densities right if you get the
number densities right and you know the
atom fraction
and you have the number density of each
isotope in the number of atoms of that
isotope cubic centimeter and then you
multiply by your cross-section your
microscopic cross-section and you get
your macroscopic cross-section yeah yep
atom fraction is a fraction between zero
and one of what proportion of the atoms
in your material are that isotope so
again if your atom fractions are outside
the bounds of zero to one that's not
physically significant if you're number
densities are around to really far from
those bounds then they're probably not
right unless you're talking about a gas
or a neutron star but solid matter tends
to have approximately those number
densities
good question you'll determine those
fractions from the ap1000 spec sheet so
in the ap1000 spec sheet it tells you
things like total weight of the fuel as
uranium dioxide and so you can go from
total weight of the fuel to let's say
molar or atom fraction of the fuel if
you know the weight of the fuel it's
nice they give you the way to the fuel
they gave you the way to the clad and
what let's see which materials did we
say you have to talk think about said
you have to talk about four materials
the coolant of the moderator water the
fuel you owe to the clotting where you
can assume piers or cone iam forget all
the crazy Zircaloy because that's just
busywork
and structural materials assume pure
iron and so on this spec sheet luckily
they just tell you the mass of the fuel
they tell you the mass of the clad I do
not believe they give you the mass of
the water but they do give you the
volume of the core and so you can figure
out if you've got a core and you
subtract off the volume of the fuel and
the weight and the cladding and the
structural materials all you're left
with this volume of the water in the
core and that'll give you your total
weight of water and once you have all
the weights then you can go to atom
fractions and then you've got all the
information you need to get the
macroscopic cross-sections is that
unclear to anybody cool so we talked
about how to get the ends let's show you
how to get the Sigma's so there was a
comment that came in that said please
teach us how to use these databases we
just kind of throw them around well I
want to teach you how to use this
database let's say we're going to get
the cross-sections for oxygen in uranium
dioxide that's nice it easy because
there's only one stable isotope of
oxygen you have to consider is oxygen 16
I highly recommend using the java
version of Janus because it is a lot
easier to use less clunky and more
intuitive so if you don't have
on your machine first of all it runs on
everything like phones tablets Linux Mac
Windows whatever and second of all it'll
just make your life easier so a little
time investment now will make the piece
that take less so once you have Java it
should just open cleanly and it may show
up with nothing it may show up something
depending on what you last looked at in
this case it's looking at whatever last
library I looked at so let's pretend
we're starting over so sometimes you may
just see this database as NEA
that's the that's all the databases that
come with Janis we expand this make sure
that you go to incident Neutron data
because these are cross-sections for
Neutron reactions that we want to go for
and there are a lot of databases in here
and in the problem set specifically say
to use the most recent en d.f or
evaluated nuclear data file just to make
sure that we're all using the same data
set you'll notice that there are
discrepancies between the data so
different groups have measured things
with different uncertainties and
different values and so these
cross-sections are necessarily
fundamental constants of nature they're
measurements of those constants with
whatever uncertainty and error which are
two separate things that could be in
there so let's open up the most recent
endif library and click on
cross-sections and now whatever you see
here the green squares are the elements
that have tabulated cross-sections just
to make sure that we only have to
consider oxygen-16
let's go to the table of nuclides we'll
never stop using this table it's like
the most useful thing in this class and
check to make sure that there's no other
stable isotopes of oxygen that we have
to worry about as long as the Internet's
working
did they immigrate to Korea website
crashed to
interesting well we'll let that load for
a bit and let's start looking at
oxygen-16
so if you double-click on the element of
interest it'll usually take a little
while because it's Java it's loading
cross-sections and then you can pick the
nuclear reaction of choice from here and
unfortunately I can't easily make this
bigger I will take a very quick detour
and see if I can make these things a bit
larger so you can see them but if not
then whatever no no oh well so let's say
you wanted to get the elastic scattering
cross-section for oxygen the first the
first letter before the comma is going
to be the incident particle notice that
sometimes it says N and sometimes it
says Z and specifically means neutrons z
means whatever incident particle you
chose so we know that here Z means
neutrons coming in and elastic that's
elastic scattering so we can then click
on cross-section if you want to see what
it looks like you can check P for plot
and this will give you a logarithmic
plot of the scattering cross-section as
a function of energy you can see that
it's pretty boring for oxygen there
aren't a lot of nucleons there aren't a
lot of different energy levels there are
not that many resonances or things going
on so I wouldn't be that upset if you
just approximated the fast scattering
cross-section for argon as that value
whatever it is but let's do this
completely let's tabulate this so if you
click on T you actually get a table of
data and you can choose how much data
you export by default you get like
thousands upon thousands of entries
which is just gonna make your life
horrible so what you can do is either
pick the original values starting at one
evey and we know we only have to go up
to ten MeV so you can pick your bounds
and all of a sudden there is
only a few thousands worth of data or
you can interpolate them you can
interpolate values either linearly or
logarithmically I recommend logarithmic
because this is such a large energy
range and get maybe five values per
decade so between one and ten MeV you
only need five numbers that's still
pretty intense oh I didn't uncheck the
original values ah isn't that better
so now there's only 20 or 30 entries it
glosses over the residences it sure does
but are they that important that's up to
you guys to decide you can try doing one
of these calculations with the original
values and with the interpolated values
and see just how different they really
are in to group theory and hint is not
very much so then you can actually
export that data so either you can just
copy paste it so I just highlighted
copied start Excel and in it comes and
right there's the data that you can
start to use to do your numerical
integration and I don't want to give
away how to do the numerical integration
though I kind of did symbolically I'd
like you guys how to figure out how to
do this numerical integration
mathematically given that you can get
the data now so is there any step here
that's unclear to anyone yeah
every single material yes you are sounds
horrible isn't it that's why I made some
simplifications so if you notice we are
simplifying the cladding as Zr and we're
simplifying stainless steel as pure iron
I don't want you guys to just do tons
and tons of repetitive stuff but I do
want you to get roughly the right answer
I want you to answer that question so
how would you consider the isotopes of
uranium in this question that's right
it's not the natural values it's the
enriched values so they will say in the
spec sheet
you wanna don't want to be on a list you
don't have to look up and rich to
uranium on Google you can look it up on
Janus so if you go to Janus right are
you looking for what the enrichment
level is yeah oh that's in the ap1000
spec sheet where'd it go we search for
enrichment fuel enrichment first cycle
weight percent
you can either average these or just
pretend it's five because that's that's
a pretty pretty typical enrichment level
is 5% atomic fraction u-235 or if you
want to get really technical you can
average these noting how many fuel
assemblies are in each of the regions
but I don't really care if you do that
you 238 yep so there's only two isotopes
of uranium one of oxygen however many of
iron and zirconium hint there's not that
many and then there is h2o and there's
only one hydrogen and one oxygen so it's
not really that much busy work it's just
enough for you to get to the right
answer so I wouldn't even call it busy
work because there's a point to it so in
that way you can determine all of these
cross sections we give you these fluxes
these new values you can also get from
Janus they're not labeled as new but
they are labeled as Neutron
multiplication factor and they're
usually way down here and we probably
need to find a fissile isotope for that
so let's ditch oxygen for now go up to
uranium
okay so let's do you 235 it'll pull up
the data and then near the bottom
noubar total neutron production check it
out for pretty much all energies until
you get to the fast region it's the
value we talked about two point four
four and then in the fast region you
suddenly can get more neutrons from
fission why do you guys think that is
well what sort of additional things
happen when you're incident particle
energy increases let's think back to
binding energy and all the stuff at the
beginning of the course there's more
different kinds of fission products that
can be made because you're increasing
the Q value of this reaction by
increasing the initial kinetic energy so
there are more fission products that can
be made and some of them let's say give
off more neutrons than others so you'll
be able to get your noubar total from
this one near the bottom and everything
else will be near the top they'll either
be a fission cross-section an absorption
cross-section a scattering cross-section
how do you get your diffusion
coefficients
they're not tabulated but they're close
yep exactly
so let's render this nicely the
diffusion constant is one over three
times the total cross-section minus mu
not scattering average average average
and this average cosine is sorry about
two-thirds times the atomic mass so you
can get these diffusion coefficients
from tabulated data the total cross
section is found at the top better wise
better known as well it's just as total
so you can get total cross-sections here
the only one that might be a little
tricky for you to find from notation is
absorption you're not going to see
something labeled absorption in this
database however you will see this gamma
reaction or how else do you get it if
you take the total - fission
- scattering you're left with absorption
if you don't count end-to-end reactions
or really esoteric high-energy things so
if you can't find it that's okay because
you can calculate it because we know
Sigma absorption is Sigma total minus
Sigma scattering minus Sigma fission -
others that we don't care about and
since you're getting these anyway
tabulating Sigma absorption should be
trivial it's just an Excel subtraction
yep
yep inelastic scattering is not
considered absorption so inelastic
scattering means one neutron goes in one
neutron comes out but at a very
different energy level so I guess we
would also say minus Sigma in elastic
and inelastic does happen for just about
every other element but the nice thing
is those don't turn on until about one
MeV so it's not going to matter much but
you can quantify how much it matters and
just check so if you can make a
justified assumption to say here's the
one of the calyx with and without
inelastic scattering and if they don't
differ by much then forget it
as long as you show me your math so
let's say we've got news we have
cross-sections I give you fluxes we have
DS you can calculate buckling from the
geometry of the reactor which is given
in the ap1000 spec sheet the only other
trick will be what's Sigma scattering
from fast to thermal so you'll have to
figure out what is the cross section not
just of scattering total but the cross
section or the probability that a fast
Neutron enters the thermal group and I
don't want to give that away either but
it's not terribly mathematical yep
not quite so even if you only have one
isotope for each material if you have
more than one material you've got to
average those cross sections because
this criticality criterion is for the
entire reactor and all the stuff in it
that's why it's like in a blender so
even if iron has one isotope and
zirconium as one isotope and uranium has
one isotope which wouldn't really be a
reactor then you'd still have to take
atom fractions of those to get the total
criticality condition speaking of which
I forgot to write where the K is and
since everything else here will be
tabulated you can solve for K effective
so K effective is the only variable
unknown in this whole equation
yep that's right
so yeah let's go to the rest of the
problem set since you mentioned it for
one of the other questions North Korean
nuclear weapons why is it that just
putting together a super critical mass
of plutonium does not constitute an
effective bomb we're lucky for that too
that making nuclear weapons is a lot
harder than just getting nuclear
material and this is a lot of the reason
why there's a been you know 500 tonne
yield or kiloton yields duds it's really
really really really hard and I want you
to think about what would you need to do
to turn a super critical mass of nuclear
material into an effective weapon and
why is it that it's so difficult to do
and actually really glad it's so
difficult to do it's one of the reasons
that a lot of folks don't have them but
yeah if you only have one isotope like
you do in this problem you don't have to
do atom fractions you just take number
density times microscopic cross-section
from Janus and you get the macro
cross-sections that's why it's one of
the skill building problems where it's
it shouldn't be that hard so you'll have
a criticality condition you'll be able
to get cross-sections and number
densities and you'll be able to tell
what that radius of the sphere is given
the form of buckling for a sphere which
would be in your reading yep
that's being sent to you today so
everyone oh so you guys all did power
manipulations from the reactor I wanted
to get him from Monday the guys were
busy doing an in core experiment
installed they've promised me the data
today so you guys will be able to take a
look at it and using the transient stuff
that we talked about Tuesday explain why
it doesn't look the linear feedback or
intuitive yep so we'll also I'll be
giving each of you that data today we
talked about nuclear weapons there's top
one I want you to do on your own because
it's other repetitions of the intuitive
criticality examples that we did on
Tuesday the last one we haven't talked
about is the ultra cold nuclear reactor
or the will see problem so here I want
you to actually get a criticality
condition for the case where you can
have ultra cold neutrons where your
moderator is let's say liquid hydrogen
really really cold way below the thermal
level and you have to split your reactor
into three energy groups fast thermal
and ultra cooled and the trick to this
here is somebody asked can you ever have
ultra up scattering why yes if you have
an ultra cold moderator but you've got
hot fuel you can actually scatter up in
energy where the surrounding atoms could
be hotter than some of the neutrons
hitting it and will impart energy to
those neutrons and send it up the energy
spectrum yep
mmm well how do you get old for cold
neutrons mm-hmm but some of them might
scatter up yeah they can scatter about
they can scatter down by hitting
something cold and scatter back up by
getting knocked by a hot item yeah so
it's all gonna be in the formulation of
the equations for this problem like 80
or 85 percent of the credit is did you
formulate the three group equations
correctly so I want you to think about
what are the actual sources and sinks in
each case what are the fractions of
prompt and delayed neutrons where do
they go and what terms matter where so
it's doing this but for the case that
we've given you here solving it is a lot
of algebra and therefore not a lot of
credit so is that clear to everybody
figured this piece up with worth
explaining and not just saying have fun
you know I'll see you on Piazza Sunday
night yeah that's why I check it yeah
cool I've also got problem set four for
everybody here I want to mention a
couple of quick things please when you
if you handwrite your psets which is
fine please make sure to scan them
legibly and to write legibly
we can't give partial credit for things
we can't read and so this will be a
lesson to some of you guys so depending
on who got what grade there are times
when you may have written stuff for
partial credit but we just honestly
couldn't make it out so please do make
sure that your submissions are legible
and for things like these these are
handwritten problem sets but they were
scanned with either a scanner which does
the correct contrast or writing them on
one note which apparently works pretty
well or apps like cam scanner
there's an app on your phone you can get
that scans pieces of paper and
automatically contrast enhances them it
knows the paper should be white and the
writing should be black and it also does
it in color so if you do color graphs it
recognizes that there are multiple
colors and will take care of that for
you
it only takes an additional minute but I
can give you you know double the points
and a problem set because we can read
stuff so I'll give back pset for now
we're working on five and six
the big delay in grading there was I
went to Russia and Russia doesn't have
as much internet as we do at least not
where I was and it was busy so working
on those solutions now yeah yep oh okay
yeah good question so problem one
throwing quarters into the directly into
the core like a wishing well it used to
be that back in the day they would take
folks on reactor tours to look down into
the core because when the lid is off you
can see it you can see the Cherenkov
radiation the nice blue light you can
actually see the fuel elements because
the water is sufficient shielding for
you and the distance is sufficient
shielding to keep you away from the
gammas not to mention the reactor is
usually off when the lid is off so it's
not that hot problem is you can't watch
what everyone's doing all the time and
someone he dropped a quarter into the
reactor they were like oh it's a wishing
well well it took something like six
dive robots to go into the core and fish
it out because each of those robots
lasts you know 10 minutes before the
intense radiation fries it and if you
didn't find the corridor you got to take
into out put down another one and these
are like radiation hard you know narrow
whatever diving robots this story was
relayed to me through someone that
related to them through whatever so it's
been through the telephone chain but I
dunno that's one of the big reasons you
can't look down on the core anymore it's
because folks abused the privileges of
torus yeah
yep interesting then you could use the
web version which is just through the
blah browser and no plugins required
yeah cool any other questions about the
pset that we didn't cover together does
looking a little more doable
you